signée france françois mitterrand ne m'a
pas court circuiter michel rocard est
allé cet après midi à flins chez renault
il en a profité pour remettre les choses
au point beaucoup avaient remarqué son
silence au moment où le président de la
république montait au créneau sur les
bas salaires pour le premier ministre
l'accord est total entre matignon et
l'elysée
michel lemaire c'est sur un ton plutôt
bon enfant que les salariés de renault
ont réclamé au premier ministre venu
leur rendre visite à flins de penser à
leur salaire une occasion pour michel
rocard au cours de rencontres avec le
comité d'établissement et les syndicats
de confier qu'il était en plein accord
avec françois mitterrand sur la
nécessité de réévaluer les bas salaires
on avait perçu dans le temps du chef de
l'état une certaine impatience
michel rocard ne l'a pas entendu de la
même oreille j'avais besoin dit il que
françois mitterrand face aux pressions
pour que les partenaires sociaux
engagent des négociations
c'était donc aussi une sorte de coup de
chapeau aux vertus de la politisation
tracts ul qui était venu donner à flins
michel rocard dans une entreprise qui
représente de ce point de vue un certain
symbole vernet clin d'oeil avant de
quitter lusine un petit tour au volant
de la dernière née de la régie la clio